[Music]
on this Wednesday night holding steady
why the Bank of Canada is keeping its
key interest rate at status quo and why
experts are not putting their money on
another hike the investigation into an E
coli outbreak at six Calgary daycares
Taiwan answers the growing anger among
parents a challenge from a chip company
blamed for a teenager's death the
warning from doctors
and Still rocking now try to call my
baby on the telephone the Rolling Stones
first album of original songs in 18
years
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us if you
were worrying about another hike in
interest rates you can breathe easy for
now the Bank of Canada held its key
interest rate steady today at five
percent the bank has been on a roll
recently raising rates 10 times since
March of 2022 to try to reduce consumer
spending rates haven't been this High
since April of 2001. in our top story
tonight Mackenzie gray explains why the
bank is holding steady for now
the Bank of Canada holding the line
keeping rates at 20-year highs the
run-up in interest rates in the past
year and a half are really now finally
beginning to uh to Bear Down on on the
consumer Canadian spending less has sent
the economy into what the bank calls a
period of weaker growth which is the
goal of Governor Tiff Macklin he wants
to slow down the economy in reduced
demand to bring inflation in line but
that's a strategy that could lead to
more pain you give the Bank of Canada
two options one is the recession the
other is inflation they will take a
recession any day despite 10 rate hikes
the bank believes inflation and wages
will Trend upwards in the coming months
with salaries growing at five percent
the bank believes Canadians are making
too much money to get inflation down
leading them to warn their ready to
raise rates again but that option is
viewed as unlikely they probably won't
need to raise rates again but there is a
possibility and I think the bank did not
want to you know shut down that that
possibility today's decision keeping
premers happy with new Democrats in
British Columbia liberals in
Newfoundland and conservatives in
Ontario all in the past week telling the
Independent Bank to hold rates enough is
enough
you're trying to kill the economy
Federal NDP leader jagmeet Singh taking
it a step further calling for the prime
minister to get involved it's time for
Justin Trudeau whose government sets the
Mandate for the Bank of Canada to
clearly give the message that policies
that hurt workers and herd families are
wrong meddling in the independence of
the bank and non-starter for Christian
Freeland as Finance Minister I fully
respect the independence of the Bank of
Canada as it delivers on its mandate to
return inflation to Target one thing not
discussed lowering interest rates CIBC
predicting that won't come until the
middle of next year Donna at the
earliest
okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Ontario has a new housing Minister
because the last one resigned after the
province's Integrity commissioner found
he violated ethics rules it's about the
plan to open up protected Green Space
around Toronto to developers two
investigations have now found that
process was Hasty and flawed and favored
certain developers over others the new
housing minister is promising a review
of all of it will be open and
accountable Colin Demello is with me
from Queens Park in Toronto Colin does a
new Minister mean a new approach what's
different now well to put it in terms of
housing Donna the structure might be
changing but the foundation Remains the
Same Ontario's new Minister of Housing
Paul Calandra said today that he agreed
and supported the initial decision to
remove lands from the green belt because
he believed they were necessary to
construct 1.5 million homes the Minister
of Housing says he is pushing forward
with construction on those pieces of
land and he's looking at all of the
green belt 2 million Acres of it to see
which lands could be or should be
removed moved the only difference the
minister says is this time the process
will be more ethical it will look at the
entirety of the green belt there may be
lands that need to be added to the green
belt there may be some uh some lands
that are removed but it'll be a fair and
open process that will live up to the
spirit of the original uh intent of the
agreement Paul Paul Calandra is new to
the role of housing Minister but he's
been around the block in politics right
yeah Paul Calandra is known in political
circles as someone who is a gifted
speaker but is also a hyper partisan and
a political attack dog when needed he
was the Parliamentary assistant to
former Prime Minister Stephen Harper
when he was going through the Senate
expense Scandal and even here at Queen's
Park history is someone repeating itself
Paul Calandra was parachuted in to the
ministry of long-term care when the
former Minister resigned and didn't run
for re-election it was a sensitive time
in that Ministry coming out of the
pandemic now the minister is being
called on again to deal with another
housing file that's seemingly Under Fire
and the minister is expected to clean up
the mess of the Ford government's latest
Calamity Donna all right Colin Demello
in Toronto thanks
three weeks after wildfires forced them
to flee their homes about 20 thousand
residents of Yellowknife are making the
Journey Back Home
and already out on the streets I can see
a lot more traffic and and folks getting
out it's nice to get you know a bit of
that normal feeling back
the mayor of the territorial capital is
welcoming people back many have been
gone since August 16th the last Highway
roadblock impeding access was lifted at
11 A.M and commercial flights to the
city resumed around the same time
officials are warning some services will
still take a few days to be completely
set up
the summer of 2023 is the hottest ever
recorded in the northern hemisphere
Global sea surface temperatures are
unprecedented Antarctic sea ice is
unprecedentedly low for this time of
year and it was the the hottest or
August on record by a big margin
it was the third straight month in a row
to set such a record following the
hottest ever June and July according to
the European Union's Copernicus climate
change service the global average
temperature this summer reached
16.77 degrees Celsius that's 0.29
degrees above the previous record set in
2019 at this point 2023 is the second
warmest year on record and climate
scientists expect it will jump to first
place as heat waves continue to bake
parts of the world
the number of young children suffering
after an E coli outbreak in Calgary is
growing Alberta Health Services says at
least 96 confirmed cases are linked to
one Central Kitchen that prepares food
for close to a dozen daycares in the
city the exact source of the
contaminated food isn't clear but as
Joel senec reports the nature of the
outbreak May provide some Clues
put your shoes on Daniel Redwood is
searching for answers she's been caring
for her sick three-year-old son since
the weekend he had quite a bit of
diarrhea and wasn't sleeping really well
the cause an E coli infection Redwood
sun is one of almost 100 confirmed cases
in Calgary with more than 20 kids in
hospital officials say a handful are
dealing with more severe complications I
want them to be
um holding the people responsible
responsible the outbreak is impacting
almost a dozen day care centers in and
around the city our main focus thus far
has been to prevent any additional
transmission or spread of this and to
ensure that children are safe and have
access to any care that they may need
Alberta Health Services says all the
impacted sites share a central kitchen
one food safety expert believes that
points to a probable Source it's likely
across contamination event of some sort
as opposed to a general food that other
people are also buying and consuming
fueling brains operates more than half
the impacted daycare sites in a
statement its co-founder says the exact
source of the outbreak has not been
identified but we will be reviewing our
policies procedures and sourcing related
to food services for our facilities it's
not like a little kid came to school
sick and got a couple other kids sick
they literally literally fed it to them
and that makes me angry
redwood's son wasn't admitted to
hospital but is still undergoing testing
every 24 hours her son's recovery is her
priority and she says she's lost faith
in those trusted to care for him and
dozens of other children
Jewel senec Global News Calgary
there are growing concerns tonight about
a social media challenge involving
eating extremely spicy chips it might
sound funny but it can be dangerous the
Dare is to eat ships dusted with two of
the world's hottest peppers That's Mike
drolets it's being blamed for the death
of a teenager in the U.S
that was bad it's a marketing tour de
force that's as simple as it is
dangerous
eat a chip oh God suffer post reaction
online and then watch the views multiply
milk
the company that created the one chip
challenge offers a warning that its chip
is intended for adult consumption but
anybody in the U.S and Canada can
legally buy it this is like deliberately
saying let's find different ways for
these kids to hurt themselves and now
the family of a 14 year old boy outside
of Boston is blaming the chip challenge
for his death Harris wallaba reportedly
was sent home after eating a chip at
school and then died hours later in
hospital while autopsy results are still
pending the medical community is using
wallaba's case as a warning that extreme
spice can be dangerous what it does is
it actually
activates a receptor that makes you
think you have intense pain
so it causes intense pain but it also is
irritant so it can cause irritation and
and it can cause things like it can
disrupt the can disrupt the esophagus
capsaicin is what gives the chip bite
it's an extract from Peppers that Health
Canada lists as an animal repellent
since it's used in bear spray it can be
consumed but there's a risk the two
Peppers that are used in the chip are
rated so hot they make a jalapeno pepper
seem positively mild what's happening in
my body there's no shortage of TV shows
that use risk to draw viewers
and those in turn have helped fuel
interest in increasingly dangerous
challenges that act as click bait
there's a lot of room for
experimentation for having fun for
taking risks so often it doesn't feel
totally real right like it doesn't feel
like it's necessarily the real world but
it rather it's kind of like a media
representation of the world so that
often makes risk taking a bit easier the
challenge trend is proving difficult to
control and what makes it most worrisome
there's always another challenge on the
horizon micro Lake Global News Toronto
Russia's deadly daytime attack on
Ukraine
coming up the moment people realize they
had to scramble to safety
at least 31 people have been killed in
hundreds are now homeless after a
cyclone slammed Southern Brazil Drone
footage shows the extent of the
destruction homes ripped apart roads
covered in mud it is the latest weather
disaster in Brazil more than 50 people
were killed in Sao Paulo State earlier
this year after downpours caused
landslides and flooding
in Ukraine Russia attacked an outdoor
Market in the Donetsk region killing at
least 17 people
injured it is one of Russia's deadliest
strikes in months the Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski condemned
it calling it a deliberate attack on
civilians in a peaceful city as Crystal
gemancing Reports it coincides with a
visit to Ukraine by a top U.S Diplomat
and a warning some of the images in the
story are graphic
foreign a graphic scene of death and
destruction following an attack on a
market in Costa tivnifca
those who know the city and its layout
can clearly say it was civilian
infrastructure there is no military base
anywhere near since the Ukrainian
president
foreign
people on the street could be seen
reacting to the initial sound before the
moment of impact
I saw a Flash and then shouted to my
colleagues lie on the floor says this
Pharmacy employee in the blast area
the horrific and deadly midday attack on
the industrial city in the Donetsk
region occurred the same day the U.S
Secretary of State made an unannounced
visit to keep
Anthony blinken met with numerous
Ukrainian officials offering in-person
reassurance acknowledging progress of
their counter-offensive saying it had
accelerated and announced a new Aid
package of more than a billion dollars
bringing America's contribution to
Ukraine to more than 60 billion dollars
we are determined the United States
continue to walk side by side with you
the capital was also targeted Wednesday
by a series of pre-dawn attacks
triggering keeves air defense system
falling debris caused some damage in
residential areas
as for the deadly attack on Costa
Technica Ukrainian president vlodimir
zielinski wrote on social media this
Russian evil must be defeated as soon as
possible Crystal gemancing Global News
London
[Music]
started still going strong
today Canada became the latest strategic
partner of the association of Southeast
Asian Nations it is a symbolic gesture
by the 10 Nation block and according to
prime minister Justin Trudeau shows
Canada's clear commitment to the region
he vows to boost trade ties while
working with the Nations to protect the
environment turia Israeli is traveling
with the prime minister
Jakarta Indonesia has a title No
Metropolis wants the most polluted city
on earth
the capital is also sinking and some
neighborhoods could be underwater by
2050.
all consequences of explosive growth
and a changing climate affecting every
Pacific Nation Canada is in the midst of
our worst Wildfire season ever
and this kind of terrible happening
isn't limited to Canada prime minister
Justin Trudeau traveled to The asean
Summit in Jakarta to sell Canada as a
Trailblazer in Green Technology Canada
is becoming the reliable supplier of
clean energy a net zero world needs
Indonesia is the largest country in
Southeast Asia and also Canada's largest
trading partner in the region both
countries did six billion dollars in
business last year there are huge
economic opportunities and also huge
challenges especially when it comes to
climate change
Canada has the resources southeast Asia
needs to transition but not necessarily
the capacity our ports are going to need
to expand we have critical minerals in
Canada but we don't have a road or train
track to get them there another
challenge
overcoming Canada's reputation as an
inconsistent partner asean leaders hope
this latest Outreach lasts because now
Ottawa has an indo-pacific strategy
again a rather new development which we
in the region find a rather fresh a
prescient
move on the part of Canada Canada is in
the middle of trade negotiations with
asean countries but this Summit is
wrapping up with few details about when
an agreement will be reached Donna the
government will only say these types of
talks are complex and take time
Victoria Israeli in Jakarta thanks Taria
one of Nova scotia's best known
singer-songwriters has died the family
of Bruce guthro says he passed away
Tuesday night after a long battle with
cancer
[Music]
guthro was born in Cape Breton and his
exceptional songwriting and singing
connected him with people all over the
world he was the front man for the
long-running Scottish Band Run rig he
won a number of East Coast Music Awards
over his 40-year career and was known
for his series of songwriter circles
with up-and-coming artists in Canada
Bruce guthro was 62 years old
the oldest performing rock and roll band
in history is making headlines again
[Applause]
the Rolling Stones were in East London
today launching their first album of
original songs since 2005 and the first
since the death of drummer Charlie Watts
Mick Jagger who is 80 now along with
Keith Richards and Ronnie Wood are the
surviving Corps of the 61 year old group
Hackney diamonds East London slang for
broken glass features guest stars like
Lady Gaga and Stevie Wonder and it was
no easy feat putting it together oh yeah
I keep my chops together between gigs
and uh it's you've got to keep your
fingers moving when you get to outrage
yeah keep everything moving
for why it took so long to
produce we've been pretty lazy that was
a blessed song
it's not very quick at all we have done
something we're not on the road most of
the time the album comes out October
20th but they teased it today with a
single called angry we're back in a
moment
okay
Canada's men's national basketball team
has already achieved its main goal at
the international basketball Federation
World Cup it's qualified for the team's
first Olympics in decades and now it's
clinched its first ever semi-final spot
at the men's basketball World
Championships Eric Sorensen reports on
why it seems the sky's the limit for
this team
how good is this Canadian team we're
still learning led by Shea gilges
Alexander who at times makes scoring
against the best players in the world
look easy the Hamilton Ontario native
scored 31 points making the case that he
may be the best player at the World Cup
take it from slovenia's Superstar Luca
doncic congratulations to Canada a very
physical game they have one of the best
players in the world so it was really
tough to guard him as Canada pulled away
in the second half others also stepped
up it could be anybody I mean of course
Shea is the head of the snake he's
always going to do what he does but it
could be anybody on our team that has
that night and I think that's one of
that's one of our strengths Canada came
into the World Cup ranked 15th in the
world but they've now beaten Slovenia
walloped France and surprised Spain the
top ranked team in the world so Canada
and three more higher ranked teams now
advance to the semi-finals first time
ever for this country Canada will play
Serbia the U.S will take on Germany the
winners will meet in the gold medal
final but the other two will play for
bronze so Canada is guaranteed to play
for a medal for the first time at the
World Cup the Slovenian coach says
Canada could win it all Canada have a
hell of a team I mean they can play
different lineups they have guys who can
create so they have
everything they they need to go all the
way I think they can match up United
States and that's saying something for a
team that only seems to be getting
better almost every quarter that they
play with each other the chemistry
builds and builds it just feels like
there's a momentum building with the
team game by game and they're on the
verge it feels like there's something
very special we want to win you know we
want to win every time we step out on
the floor not only for ourselves for our
country early Friday morning from Manila
Canada against Serbia will this team
continue to make history Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers globalnational.com
and thanks for watching hope to see you
here again tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]